[Music]
let's go on a little loud house
adventure if you watch our videos you've
seen what these characters look like
reimagined as someone else but you
haven't seen them in action and all that
is about to change don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up and subscribe to
the things now let's get to the video
our story begins with Lincoln loud we
all know he has a vivid imagination but
have you ever wondered what his dreams
might look like
well let's enter his dreams and find out
on our own whoa what's this Lincoln
wakes up and he immediately transforms
into an adorable Mickey Mouse the
question is is the rest of his family
transformed too he opens the door to the
second floor where the rest of his
siblings live and decides to go check on
them he immediately opens lori and
Lenny's room to see if his older sisters
are okay Lincoln couldn't find Laurie
but he just assumed she's with Bobby but
it looks like whatever happened turns
Linney into a gorgeous Cinderella she
didn't seem to mind either but Lincoln
still wasn't sure what was happening he
goes to check on his other sisters Luna
and Luann's room is pretty dark but it
seems like only one of the girls got to
be a villain Lincoln gasps at Luna as
she transforms into the Evil Queen while
Luanne becomes Belle having these two in
the same room just calls for more
trouble but did anyone else turn into a
Disney character by now Lincoln gets
curious he goes into Lin's and Lucy's
room and while Lucy's nowhere to be
found
he's stunned by Lin's Disney
transformation she's an actual villain
Lucy would probably get really jealous
considering how she's always the one
that's dressed in dark and gets really
moody Lincoln is pretty amused but still
has no idea what is happening so he
laughs and leaves to check on the twins
just the thought of the twins dressed as
Disney characters is hilarious Lincoln
goes into the twins bedroom lada must
have been doing some tinkering around
the house but lo the transforms into
Ariel she doesn't seem to mind either
and she is pretty excited to have a
mermaid tell
we'll definitely separate the twins even
more finally Lincoln goes to check on
Lisa and Lily Lily must be with her
parents but Lincoln is shocked by Lisa's
look she's dressed as Moana it's the
first time he's seen her in anything
other than her regular clothing but she
seems to be totally rocking that costume
all she needs to do now is give us her
own rendition of the songs in Moana and
we're totally on board with this Lincoln
goes back in the hallway and suddenly
sees the villains Lynn and Luna arguing
as soon as he comes out the two turned
to him
Lincoln sees the rage in their eyes and
he hopes Luna doesn't also have the evil
Queens powers but when he sees her offer
Lynn Ursula a red apple Lincoln knows he
needs to put a stop to it he starts
running but right before he reaches the
Apple he suddenly wakes up he checks his
arms his legs and looks in the mirror
he's no longer Mickey Mouse he's back to
his old self he takes a deep breath and
opens his bedroom door to check on his
sisters do you think they're still in
their Disney outfits let us know in the
comments below
and that's all for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
tell us how you felt about this video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]